Європейські політики закликають Росію й Україну
не допускати подальшої ескалації в Азовському морі
і наполягають на вирішенні ситуації мирним шляхом
В іншому випадку в ЄС не виключають
що через конфлікт у Керченській протоці закликами до деескалації
справа не обмежиться
і щодо Росії буде вжито відповідних заходів
Ми не визнаємо дій Росії і готові розширити санкції
якщо Російська Федерація продовжить діяти такими методами
Ми хочемо, щоб українські кораблі і людей, які знаходилися на борту, звільнили
Позиція Європейського Союзу абсолютно чітка
ми хочемо захистити права України
Після незаконної анексії Криму Росією ми не можемо прийняти той факт
що Азовське море, як цього прагне Москва
крок за кроком ставатиме територіальними водами Росії
Питання про введення подальших санкцій Євросоюз може розглянути вже 10 грудня
Про це напередодні заявила міністерка закордонних справ Австрії Карін Кнайсль
Її ініціативу підтримали представники Естонії і Польщі
При цьому, Німеччина і Франція пропозицію про посилення санкцій щодо Москви відкинули
Єдності щодо того, які заходи могли б стати
пропорційною відповіддю на дії Росії в Азовському морі
у політиків поки немає, зазначають експерти
При цьому, на думку багатьох з них, одних закликів до деескалації явно недостатньо.
Якщо ми згадаємо, то вперше Україна скаржилася на дії Росії
в Азовському морі ще в 2016 році
Тоді порушення Росією міжнародного морського права
в цьому регіоні тільки набирали обертів
А те, що відбувається тепер,
особливо з квітня цього року
свідчить про часті порушення.
Вони блокують Україні доступ до Керченської протоки
І це те, що не можна ігнорувати
І тут не обійтися також без чіткої і сильної позиції Дональда Трампа
Як повідомляють російські ЗМІ
Україна почала переговори із США про створення військової бази на території країни
У той же час президент США Дональд Трамп відмовився
від запланованої зустрічі з Володимиром Путіним
на саміті Великої двадцятки в Аргентині
При цьому США закликають Європу застосувати більш жорсткі санкції щодо Росії
Багато держав ввели санкції щодо Росії за її дії в Криму, в Україні,
але не всі із запроваджених заходів виконуються
Крім того, ми вже багато разів про це говорили, але, можливо, недостатньо.
Європейські країни повинні переглянути свою позицію
щодо "Північного потоку-2".
Росія, як і раніше, робить ставку на дипломатію труб, зазначають експерти.
Але на тлі ескалації в Азовському морі
аклики до відмови від "Північного потоку-2"
стали звучати частіше і в Європі.